people to those incarcerated to those
from the hoods that we come from
east point south side of chicago
brooklyn
l.a south central wherever you're from
in this country
we deserve to be heard we deserve to
stand up for the people we need leaders
that think about the people
that have compassion for the people that
listen to the people
that care for the people and are willing
to give everything
to stand for the people
[Music]
my people
[Music]
latino asian people
[Music]
legal my daughter found emo i found a
new primo
oh you know how we do we do it for the
people the struggle of the brothers and
the folks
lovers of the dope experiment to
discover hope scuffle for notes
the rougher i wrote times was harder
went for rocket starter
the voice of armada some white folk
focus on tarzan yoga
my people on the low and trying to ball
it get over
lyrics the light liquor for the fallen
soldier to bounce to the house
it's all our culture every day we
hustling
trying to get them customs law we ain't
trusting them big ones
we lusting them sick and tired of
punching it i look on the bus at them
when i see them struggling i think
[Music]
people
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
music affected lives a gift from the
skies
to be recognized
[Music]
my people from georgia
[Music]
who is with the people
about the people
[Music]
[Music]
standing for our women for our children
for the latino community
for the lgbt community
for the people children of god
we stand for the people
you know one of the things that's making
me so happy being here i'm so grateful
voting is such a beautiful thing because
it brings together people
for a common purpose no pun intended or
not but
but one of the beautiful things i see
right now is seeing our young
children right there holding up signs
they part of the process
they know their value and i got to talk
with mayor bottoms earlier and we were
talking about our children and our young
people
and just reminding them how powerful
they are
how beautiful they are how they possess
the qualities that god
has given all of us but they have it in
such a pure beautiful way
and i want to remind you all it's a lot
of changes going on
it's a lot of tough situations that's
been happening
but we got you we gonna do everything in
our in our possible
grasp to change this world and we are
doing it now for you
we doing it for our children we doing it
for you and you all are doing it just by
being who you are
so never forget who you are
[Music]
we do this for our children
[Music]
beautiful baby i love you baby i pray
these words they hug you baby
look into the mirror say i love you
daily remember your light when the world
seems shady
you born with it adorned with it a gift
to this world
gonna give it fearlessly made no need to
be afraid
angels are with you the path is laid
waiting thoughts of you being a star
truly you'll shine by seeing who you are
reflections of you
reflections of me your beauty more than
any eyes can see
who you were yes
don't forget who you are
children so blessed with it
don't forget who you are
[Music]
the first woman vice president
i want to see that in my lifetime
let's go out and support our ladies
support the women as we lift them
because they are the life
[Music]
gotta be something for me to write this
queen i ain't seen you in a minute
wrote this letter and finally decide to
send it signs he'll deliver for us to
grow together
love has no limit let's a slow forever
your heart is weathered by once thus did
to you
i ain't go subtle i did it too because
of you feelings i handed with care
brothers recognize your life they can't
handle declare hey i ain't the type to
walk around with matching search the
relationship is effort
i'm at your work be the one to make you
happiest hurt you the most
to end this near come close to the most
high regardless of what happened on him
let's rely
on y'all sing it y'all
[Music]
georgia let them know about the lights
[Music]
y'all
when i'm lost i try to find you you know
to give me space when it's time to
my heart's dictionary defines you love
and happiness
truthfully it's hard trying to practice
happiness time we committed love it was
real good had to be for me to arrive and
still feel good
[Music]
when i
[Music]
i can't hear your hands y'all
[Music]
i will be by your
[Music]
let's lift up our ladies
it feels good to be in georgia because
georgia has so much history of
heroes that i look at like dr king and
john lewis and
andrew young amelia boyton
diane nash you know
a lot of people um say man we gotta
vote because our ancestors and elders
fought for that right but not only did
they fight and die
and strategize
but they worked and empowered themselves
and gave themselves
a joy
and andrew young said to me these words
he said what are you willing to die for
live for that they were willing to die
for
justice freedom equality so they live
for it every day
in an encouraging way i want us to
celebrate
voting and make every person
black people know voting is your right
you got it
it's the way to express your power
all people know that this is your vote
this is the time
more than ever that if we vote we will
change the
trajectory and all the bad things that
occurred in this country we will be
working to change that
so go out there early vote
vote on november 3rd this is for the
soul of a nation
this is for the soul of the people this
is for us to act like human beings to
each other have leadership that cares
for the people
leadership that thinks about humanity
in a way where we all will have an
expression of voice
and a chance to be at our best and we
all deserve that that's a god-given gift
so i say to all those who came before us
i salute you
to those who are working right now and
to our young people
i salute you and all our work
we do i say to god be the glory
to god be the glory
[Music]
one day when the glory comes
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
hands to the heavens no man no weapon
formed against yes glory is destined
everyday women and land become legends
sins that go against our skin become
blessings
the movement is a rhythm to us freedom
is like religion to us
justice is such a position in us justice
for all just
ain't specific enough once son die the
spirit is revisiting us
true and living living in us resistance
is us that's why
rosa sat on the bus that's why we walked
through georgia
with our hands up when it go down we
woman and man
up they say stay down and we stand up
shots we on the ground the camera panned
up king pointed to the mountaintop and
we ran
up one day when the glory comes
it'll be eyes it'll be
eyes oh november 3rd
when the war is won we will be
sure we will be shown
all glory to god be the glory
[Music]
to the finish and then it is all done
we cry glory
glory
[Applause]
we cry glory
[Music]
[Applause]
man woman and child even jesus got his
crown in front of a crowd
they marched with the torch we go wrong
with it now never look back
we'd have gone hundreds of miles from
dark roads heroes
to become a hero facing the league of
justice power was the people the enemy
is lethal a king became rigo
saw the face of jim crow under a wrong
ego the biggest weapon
is to stay peaceful we sing our music is
the cuts that we bleed through
somewhere in a dream he had an epiphany
now we write the balls in history no one
can win a war
individually and take the wisdom of the
elders young people's energy
welcome to the story we call victory
becoming of the lord my eyes have seen
the glory yes
when the glory comes it'll be it'll be
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
same we say isaiah sharky on a good job
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
we act as children of god for each other
glory atlanta georgia
i thank you bishop murphy
william murphy keon
isaiah sharkey pj
masina abdul karim my man boom bishop
my man ali on the keys kareem
and dj dummy we're glad to be here
standing
for the soul of a nation for the biting
harris ticket
we believe in change and we know change
is here
we want to bring up someone from the
atlanta georgia area
one of your greats who has been about
voting
and he has a story to tell
i'm talking about from the great group
amigos offset
we got offset here that he been speaking
up about voting
for as long as i known the man and i
gotta say man it's just been touching my
heart to hear his story
[Music]
and hear what he's done so we wanna
bring that energy atlanta for your
homeboy
we gonna set it off and get our brother
all set up here
yeah thank you y'all god bless
[Music]
how y'all doing today
[Music]
yes sir we gonna turn it up for the
young folks out here we need to get
more of our young folks to vote you did
let's do it you know we in atlanta right
i need y'all to beat those horns and
make some noise for offset right now atm
let's go
[Music]
keep them horns blurry hands up let's go
yes sir yes sir
[Music]
[Applause]
yes sir i need to see where everybody at
right now if you having a good time make
some noise
atlanta georgia if you're ready for a
change i need you to beat those horns
right now for fighting
i need you to beat those horns for
austin if you're ready for a change in
america
if you pre-voted i need you to beat
those horns i need you to make some
noise
ain't set let's take it to that record
man
let's go please let's do it
let's go let's go
let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i just want to say one thing um this is
my first year
voting because i was told i couldn't
vote because i had a bad past
and um i just want to thank god for
allowing me to be a part of the world
because i used to feel like i wanted a
part of the world
and i just want y'all people to know if
you're young don't feel like
you need to go vote because we need to
know what's going on that's what help
our communities out
and i love y'all make some noise for
offset hit those horns for offset
[Music]
we love you at appreciate you
[Music]
the day with just a little bait
[Music]
what you
[Music]
to think real
[Music]
what to find
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
to be real
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but now it looks
i like we've got a long way to go
together
i know you refused
[Music]
[Music]
i know
[Music]
[Music]
they don't know
[Music]
down anymore
[Music]
the movie
moving yeah
[Music]
[Music]
do you want to get out
[Music]
get down on it
[Music]
how you gonna do it if you really
[Music]
[Music]
by standing on the wall
[Music]
[Music]
you gotta get
[Music]
by standing on the wall
[Music]
get down
[Music]
do you
[Music]
[Music]
while you're dancing
[Music]
baby
[Music]
get down get down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
then you'll get
[Music]
stay in her arms
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
gravity is so crazy
[Music]
captain can you hear me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
do
wow
[Music]
[Music]
but you can't allow it cause maybe
[Music]
today's event has been set up to adhere
to social distancing guidelines as
outlined by health experts in the state
of georgia
talking about it i can't complain
[Music]
please welcome mayor keisha lance
[Music]
bottoms
yeah welcome to atlanta jacket hammers
and bugs back to the mac and then
jacking the clothes
good afternoon and welcome atlanta
[Music]
100 years ago my great-grandparents
direct descendants of freed slaves
packed a horse and buggy
and left the cotton fields of rural
georgia believing
that there was a better future for their
children
in atlanta some may say they were
sharecroppers
i believe they were dreamers just a few
generations later
i stand here as mayor reminded that
though many of the dreams of my
ancestors weren't realized during their
lifetime they hoped for a better
tomorrow for their children
and believe that their work would
benefit generations not yet born
and it's with that same sacred
responsibility in our hearts
that we must continue the work
believing that we owe it to our
children's children
to stand beside her and guide america
the land that we love
[Music]
during my first year in office with
generations of my family and mine i
signed an executive order ending our
city's relationship with isis we would
not be complicit
in a policy that ripped children away
from their parents
[Music]
in less than three years we've addressed
criminal justice reform in atlanta
beginning with the elimination
of the cash bail bond system in our city
no longer do you stay in jail for petty
crimes simply because you're too poor to
pay to get out
you see the story of them
the story of they the story of me
the story of you is the story of us
when i was just eight years old i came
home from school to see my father being
led away in handcuffs
my weekly ballet lessons replaced with
weekend
visits to prisons across georgia where
good men like my dad who
who made bad decisions fill prison cells
their story is my story
it's the reason we are working to close
our city jail and turn it into a center
of equity where men
who are struggling with addiction like
my father did will be able to receive
the supportive services that they need
[Music]
where women like my mother who work two
jobs and return to school at night after
my father's incarceration are able to
access
24-hour child care services because
their story
is our story our story is your story
it's why we've already invested 250
million dollars towards achieving our
goal
of one billion dollars of affordable
housing in atlanta
[Music]
and so that our workers can afford to
live in our city with dignity
we have raised the minimum wage for city
employees to 15
an hour
[Music]
we've accomplished so much in just a
short period of time because
people showed up to vote with nearly 97
000 votes cast
832 votes made the difference in my race
for mayor
and the margins are likely to be just as
thin
in precincts across georgia in just a
week
but i believe that the same change we
have begun in atlanta will continue
across america when we
show up and vote because our communities
our children my children are counting on
us to get this election right
and what i call my biden book a journal
that i kept notes in over the course of
the campaign i wrote in june of last
year
i endorsed joe biden and i feel very
vulnerable right now
i felt vulnerable because i knew i would
have to look you in the eyes
atlanta and tell you why i put it all on
the line
to stand by joe biden but when i sat
down with joe biden last summer just a
few miles from here
from here and told him of the work we're
doing across atlanta
he asked me how could he help us do more
when he drafted his criminal justice
reform and affordable housing policies
he sent them to us in atlanta to ask if
he was doing
enough this man
joe biden who stood beside president
barack obama for eight years
did not have to ask for our input
atlanta
but he did because he remembered
our conversations
and he knew what our work meant to our
communities
so while i may have felt vulnerable over
a year ago
i stand here feeling victorious today
atlanta
because i know we will not fall for the
trickery of 2016.
we will not believe that our votes don't
make a difference
we will not be fooled into thinking that
this election
is for someone else to decide we
will not leave our children's future
in the hands of a man who behaves
worse than a child
[Music]
and then the names of three heroes of
our own city who we lost this year
congressman john lewis dr c.t
vivian dr joseph lowry and so many
others
who risked their lives so that we might
have a say in this democracy
we are reminded that there is power in
our vote
because our vote is our voice in these
united states of america
and will you show up to vote for joe
biden and kamala harris
remember in georgia we have the
opportunity to elect two senators from
our state
john ossoff and rafael warnock
[Applause]
[Music]
they will leave with the moral
confidence and compassion the character
to help joel biden restore the soul of
this nation
i said it last year when i made my
endorsement and i say it now we
know joe and as congressman clyburn has
reminded us
most importantly joe knows us
young people like maya hadley are
counting on us to get this election
right
i first met maya when she was a grady
high school student and she showed up
after school and on weekends
to volunteer with our campaign maya then
continued to make us all proud when she
helped lead the atlanta-based debate
team that won top honors
at the harvard university competition
not sure how she managed to escape going
to famu common
the best hbcu in the country
but she did pretty good and she's now
student at howard university
[Music]
and in case you can't read my shirt it
says atlanta influences everything
[Music]
in the same way atlanta flew influenced
the civil rights movement that changed
this country
and the same way atlanta influences
culture across this globe today
atlanta can and will influence the
outcome of this election
with joe biden's presence here today
he has confirmed to the nation that
georgia
is in play and atlanta i know we won't
let him down
and to tell you more
to tell you more about why with your
help
and your vote joe biden will be the next
president
of the united states i welcome to the
stage maya hadley
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much mayor bottoms not only
for what you've done for me
but what you have done for everyone who
calls atlanta their home
watching you during this pandemic has
been not only an inspiration in your
leadership
but also a symbol of what i want to
aspire to be
so thank you thank you thank you mayor
bottoms
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes
hello atlanta
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is maya hadley i'm a freshman at
howard university
a graduate of grady high school
and a proud resident of atlanta georgia
yes yes first and foremost i'm a
daughter
of reggie and kirsten hadley who
stressed the importance of compassion
honesty integrity and love
i am a granddaughter of two
great-grandmothers one of whom i call my
nana
she was all she was a schoolteacher for
42 years
instilled the importance of knowledge
and education
my other grandmother was a blue-collar
worker who worked on a factory line from
sunrise to sunset
who instilled the importance of hard
work dedication
and determination those values and
lessons that were instilled in me when i
was younger
is why i'm standing in front of you
advocating that we elect joe biden as
our next president of the united states
[Music]
there are so many reasons why it is so
important that our generation is
involved in this political process
there are so many reasons why it's
important that we understand why we need
to vote
and who we are voting for that is why i
worked on mayor
bottom's campaign in 2017 that is why i
work for reverend warnock and his
campaign for senate
and that is why i'm standing in front of
you today advocating that we vote for
joe biden as our next president of the
united states
we deserve a president who is going to
advocate for all people
who is going to unite not divide
we need a president who understands the
importance of affordable health care
who acknowledges systemic racism who
understands the difference between
equality and equity and education who is
going to fight for women's rights
who is going to fight for the
communities of the lgbtq
who who's going to fight for immigrants
and that is why i am so excited to stand
in front of you today
telling you all that i am casting my
first presidential ballot
for joe biden and kamala harris
so without further ado atlanta can you
please
help me welcome to the stage our future
president of the united states of
america
joe biden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you that incredible introduction
my name is joe biden
i'm jill biden's husband and i am
commonly running mate
you all think i'm kidding don't you
folks
it gives me so much more optimism about
the future
to see that maya
and so many inspiring young people like
maya
that's uh president trump he does not
he's having trouble being heard over
there
um they're they're
[Applause]
they're they're a very polite bunch
look folks i think uh maya you're
inspiring
so many young people like you i've met
all across america
who are getting so deeply involved
helping create the change
that you know is possible you know
of course i know you've had an
incredible role model in
markeisha lance bottoms i'll tell you
what
she is something else first of all
two things you got to know about her
when you meet her number one i
understand she's smarter than you
that's the first thing i had to learn
and the second thing is
she's got a backbone like a ramrod
and she has a moral compass that's true
north
i really admire her you've done an
incredible job mayor
you're a powerhouse of a leader and
you've helped shape and support
this campaign for the earliest days so i
want to thank you mayor bottoms for your
vision
your partnership and your commitment to
the campaign
and the people of atlanta and thank you
common
and all said i tell you what i know
that's the real reason you came
the entertainment i don't blame you but
i'll tell you what
they're great to meet them both and
they're for them energizing and sharing
their message of hope with all of us
i also want to recognize elected
officials join us today
representative billy mitchell
representative calvin smiley
smiry who have been with us from the
very beginning of this campaign
and we've got to send back to the united
states house of representatives
lucy and hank and stanford all three of
them are
first-rate congresspersons
if i win i'm going to need them badly
and by the way
nikimu i think it's important that you
win
as well along with carolyn bordeaux
folks i think we're going to surprise
the living devil out of everybody this
year
i can't tell you how important it is
that we flip the united states senate
there's no state more consequential than
georgia
in that fight you have two competitive
races here at stake
you have two great candidates are going
to need all the support they can get
reverend warnock and john also
both great candidates
no they really are and by the way
if we told you all a year ago or told
those guys out in the street
a year ago good to see you man told all
those guys out in the street there a
year ago
how competitive george was going to be
you would have all looked like one
another like you're crazy
but look it doesn't take long for people
to figure out
when the game is up you know when the
kearney show goes through town the first
time
and people find out there's no p under
any one of the three shells
the next time it comes back it doesn't
get much attention well that's what the
trump administration has done
let's give the people of georgia two new
senators who fight for your interest
not not for donald trump's interests
and not continue as purdue and others
have to make fun
of my running mate i love how these guys
try to degrade everything and everybody
it's got to stop and it's going to stop
with us folks it's go
time there's one week left
millions of americans over 60 million
americans have already
voted and millions more by the end of
this week
i believe when you use your power
the power to vote will change the course
of this country
right here in georgia with all of you
these are the final days
so keep that sense of empowerment with
you that sense of optimism
what we can do what we will do what we
can overcome what we will overcome
look folks i've been around a while but
i've never been more optimistic about
america or the american people than i am
right today but i know it's hard
over the past few months there's been so
much pain
so much suffering so much loss in
america
more than 225 000 dead americans
because of covert 19. seven 7
800 right here in georgia millions of
people are out of work
on the edge they can't see the light at
the end of the tunnel and donald trump
has given up over the weekend
as chief of staff of the white house
said i quote
we're not going to control the pandemic
at the debate last week donald trump
looked at me and said we're rounding the
corner
as my grandfather would say he's
rounding the bend
he said it's going to go away we're
learning to live with it
i told him we're not learning to live
with him you're asking people to learn
to die with
it and it's wrong
donald trump donald trump has waved the
white flag
abandoned our families and surrendered
to this virus
but the american people don't give up
they don't give
in and surely they don't cower and
neither will i
i will put in place the plan to deal
with this pandemic responsibly
bringing this country together with
testing tracing and masking
it's estimated that if we wore mass the
next few months
by his own experts in the cdc and other
agencies if we wore this mass the next
few months
we'd save 100 000
lives 100 000
it's estimated we lost over 135 000
lives so far
needlessly because he's done virtually
nothing
but still donald trump refuses to listen
to science
we shouldn't be politicizing this race
for a vaccine
we should be planning for its safe and
equitable and free
distribution when it comes and it will
providing for funding for ppe mass
gloves all the things we need to set
national standards for our schools
and our businesses to open safely
because they can
the house of representatives already
voted the money
to provide for safe opening schools but
trump was either
locked in a sand trap on his golf course
or in the bunker
in his in the white house he's not
brought anybody together
think about this all of you are old
enough you can think of any president
or there's been a national crisis who
didn't bring all the parties together in
the white house
to try to solve something he's done
nothing
nothing well i'm going to bring
democrats and republicans together to
deliver the economic relief for families
schools and businesses i said before
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the not going to
shut down the country
i'm going to shut down the virus
[Applause]
[Music]
look
donald trump crashed the economy that
barack and i left him
like everything else he's left and
inherited he squandered it
we can build back better with an economy
that rewards
work not wealth we can do it without
raising taxes on the middle class i
guarantee you
no matter what you hear this president
lying about no one making less than
seven hundred thousand dollars
or should be four hundred thousand
dollars a year will have one
penny in taxes raised not one penny it's
a guarantee
but we're going to ask we're going to
ask the wealthiest and the biggest
corporations
91 of the top corporate companies in
america paid
zero federal income tax we're going to
ask them to begin to pay their fair
share
no one will pay at a higher rate than
they paid at the beginning of the bush
administration
that's who we'll deliver tax relief for
working families
the middle class help them buy their
first home
help them pay for their health care
premiums or child care
or caring for an aged loved one trump
got a supreme court justice
and you know why he did he's cleared
everybody now to destroy the affordable
care act to take away the health care
for
20 million americans who have it and
over a hundred thousand
a hundred thousand who are covered
because they have pre-existing
conditions for the first time
including 340 340
000 georgians 100 million americans
would lose their protections for
pre-existing conditions
including more than 4 million here in
the state of georgia
complications from kova 19 are going to
become the next pre-existing condition
because of heart scar and lung scarring
allowing
insurers to jack up your premiums deny
coverage
and women will once again be able to be
charged more for their health care
just because they're women
donald trump thinks health care is a
privilege i think it's an american right
look and if we all get out and vote
you'll not only store obamacare but
we'll strengthen it and build on it
so you can keep your private insurance
if you do or choose
a medicare-like public option we'll
increase subsidies lower your premiums
and deductions
out-of-pocket spending reduce
prescription costs by
60 that's what the experts are telling
me
and they'll tell you we're going to make
sure we keep the protections
for people with preexisting conditions
and by the way
i'll protect social security and
medicare
meanwhile donald trump says
if he's re-elected he's going to change
how we fund it
ladies and gentlemen the actuary at
social security said if he does what
he's proposing
if he's re-elected social security
bankrupt
by 2023 go home and tell your parents
who work like hell for that
what that's coming up donald trump
fails to condemn white supremacy he does
he doesn't believe that systemic racism
has a problem
and he won't say black lives matter
because they
do we know they matter
that's why a season a protest has broken
out all across the nation
protesting though is not burning and
looting
violence can never be a tactic or
tolerated and it won't
but much of it is a cry for justice from
the community has long had the knees
of injustice on their necks the names of
george floyd brianna taylor
jacob blake will not soon be forgotten
not by me
not by us not by this country
[Music]
folks they're going to inspire a new
wave of justice in america
but true justice is also about jobs and
jobs at least as the mayor got done here
a 15
minimum wage and financial stability
we're going to pass a national 15
an hour minimum wage
nobody nobody
should have to work two jobs to be above
the poverty level
it's wrong we're gonna change it and by
the way when we do it
what all the experts will tell you even
the wall street types we're going to
raise
the economy raise the standard of living
for everybody
when folks at the bottom do better
everybody does better all the way up the
ladder
[Music]
we're going to give black and minority
families a real shot to own a home
start a small business send a child to
college debt free
so they can build wealth and pass on
opportunity through the generations like
everybody else who's moved to the middle
class has been able to do
we're going to invest 70 billion dollars
in our hbcus and minority serving
institutions
so students like maya studying at howard
for students at warehouse spelman
clark allen clark atlanta university the
future generations
of proud students continue to get the
very best education
and by the way in the white house i've
committed
there is going to be in the outreach
community a section of the divine nine
will be included
that's a promise you know
i've been told that i kind of grew up a
little bit of chip on my shoulder
being an irish catholic kid in the town
that kind of looked down on it
i tell you what you know i didn't
realize i do but i realize i do have a
chip on my shoulder
what i read from serious
serious people about eight months ago
something about how if i were elected
president i'd be the first president
who didn't go to an ivy league school in
a long time
like somehow it meant i didn't belong
i know senator harris would be the first
hbcu graduate to serve as vice president
[Applause]
and i say it's about time a graduate
from a state
university and hbcu graduate are in the
white house
don't tell me we can't do it because if
we're sitting there
you will be there too i promise you
[Music]
folks i'm optimistic because i know
that we can meet the challenges of the
climate crisis by unleashing american
ingenuity and manufacturing to create
millions of new high-paying jobs
investing in technology and research
folks this is all in our capacity
we can do this you know
there are there aren't a lot of pundits
who would have guessed
four years ago that the democratic
candidate for president of 2020
would be campaigning in georgia on the
final week of the election
[Applause]
or that we'd have such competitive
senate races in georgia
but we do because something's happening
here in georgia and across america
people of different races backgrounds
democrats republicans independents
they're coming together to transcend the
old divides
and show us possible and this is the
most important election
in any of your lifetimes it's a battle
as i said at the outset for the soul of
america
and we're showing who we are you and i
reverend warnock john oso all of us
this country can't afford four more
years of donald trump and mitch
mcconnell
they can't afford four more years of
leaders who think
they're the only responsible for people
who vote for them
folks i don't see america that way
this has to change it'll change with me
every american including the guys the
other side of the fence
will be seen and heard and respected by
me
if elected president there will be no
red states or blue states
they'll only be the united states of
america
[Applause]
[Music]
i was reminded of that earlier this
month when i went to the sacred grounds
of gettysburg
abraham lincoln taught us about the need
to unite a nation i was reminded of that
earlier today
when i was up in warm springs reflecting
on franklin roosevelt taught us about
the need to heal our nation folks
i'm running as a proud democrat but i'll
govern as an
american president to unite and to heal
and i promise you look at my whole crowd
work is hard for those who don't support
me
as those who do that's the job of a
president
a duty to care for everyone
so in these final days stay empowered
stay optimistic stay united
because you too have a sacred duty
the duty to vote it matters
george it matters so please vote
help get out the vote early in person
voting in georgia goes through october
30th
if you're voting by mail return your
ballot as soon as possible and make sure
everyone
you know does the same don't just take
yourself to the polls
bring your brother your sister your mom
your dad your neighbor your friends
[Music]
[Applause]
drop your ballot off in a battle box
visit iwillvote.com
ga to find the location in your
community
and remember remember the final words
left to us by your late congress and my
personal friend
an american hero john lewis he said
quote
the vote is the most powerful
non-violent change agent you have
in a democratic society he went on to
say
you must use it it's not guaranteed
you can lose it
use it you have the power to win this
election
there's nothing beyond our capacity
there's no limit on america's future
the only thing that can tear america
apart is america itself
no other nation can do it only america
can tear america apart
everybody knows who donald trump is
let's show them who we are
we choose hope over fear unity over
division
science over fiction and yes truth over
[Applause]
lies
it's time to stand up and take back our
democracy
and any place we can do it here in
georgia
we win georgia we win everything god
bless you
all and may god protect our troops
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you think you got it
[Music]
we get together
is